hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip
on how to collect a after effects
project file how to reduce it and
collect it
for passing it off to other designers or
just collecting it for yourself
to archive it and come back to it later
on so this is a really important
process that we should all be doing okay
so the first thing
we're going to do here is we're going to
look in this project file for this
particular project file
wireframe which if i double click it
this is my main
composition okay so i want everything
within this main composition to be saved
in my project file
if there were things like pre comps and
things like that
everything that's within this timeline
this is my render timeline
everything within this i want saved
everything else
outside of this is assets and elements
that i no longer need
they weren't used in the project i want
to get rid of them so the first thing i
want to do
is i want to select my wireframe
comp which is my main comp file
dependencies reduce project
okay what that's going to do is it's
going to eliminate anything
within this project that is not being
used
click that and you saw a few things
immediately disappeared
and over here after effects tells me
that 10 items that were not used by the
selected items
have been deleted so 10 objects that
were assets that weren't used in my
timeline were deleted
now you can see here in my timeline like
this wireframe
text here is turned off but it's being
used by my timeline
even if something is not actually being
seen in the timeline because it is
placed in my timeline
after effects thinks that that is still
being used so that's okay
so next i'm going to do is i'm going to
just create a couple more folders here
in my assets i'm going to create a
folder for
let's say cinema 4d
because that's what these layers are
here and they're being used i'm going to
drag them in here
so everything's nice and tidy i'm also
going to
drag this folder inside of assets i'm
also going to right click on this folder
and make sure that
solids folder is checked if this is not
checked you need to make sure and click
here
so after effects knows any solids will
go into this folder from here on out
okay so the next i'm going to do is i'm
going to
select the composition again and i'm
going to go to dependencies and i'm
going to say consolidate all footage
what this is going to do is it's going
to remove any
duplicates of footage that may have been
used in this timeline so
sometimes we have duplicates of footage
or photos
things that are used more than once that
are duplicates
of each other and after effects can
recognize that and it can
eliminate duplicates replace them with
one single asset and it reduces the file
size
of your project so in this particular
case there's no
duplicates okay and then the last step
we're going to do is we're going to
click on the composition again
go to file dependencies we're going to
collect
files okay it's going to say hey listen
we need to save this first is that okay
and here after effects is going to say
okay we're going to collect the source
files for the selected comps
it could also say all comps for all
comps or selected so
typically i use selected comps because i
always have my main
rendered out comp selected when i'm
doing this process
for reducing the the assets that aren't
being used and things like that so for
selected comps is great i don't
typically use any of these check boxes i
do look here
it's going to collect seven files 17.9
megabytes will be collected
eight effects are used that's pretty
much all i do
from here i click collect and from here
it's going to collect
everything into a folder structure that
i select
i've selected my folder here i just
click save and boom
it saves the project it collects
everything and there you go you can see
here is the
the folder structure you open it up
there's the after effects
project there is the footage with the
assets it's got the audio it's got the
cinema 4d files the textures i used
everything is there so now if i want all
i have to do is right click and say
compress and it's going to create a zip
file and everything is nice and tidy
zipped up i can package this i can send
this off to
another designer or i can archive it for
myself
that is your after effects quick tip for
collecting and reducing project files